hola pues en este primer día de tres que
se espera que se desarrollen estas
pláticas los objetivos finales ya los
mencionados son garantías de elecciones
libres por parte de la oposición y que
se levanten las sanciones por parte del
gobierno de maduro esas son las
expectativas pero que se espera para el
día de hoy concretamente se espera la
firma de un memorándum de entendimiento
que fije tres puntos el primero las
reglas acordar las reglas del proceso
esta es la metodología de estas
negociaciones el segundo es definir en
específico los puntos que se van a
abordar es decir si se va a hablar
únicamente de política o también de
otros asuntos como la economía y el
tercero es definir la agenda de las
reuniones futuras es decir un cronograma
para las pláticas que tendrán lugar
después de estos tres días acá en méxico
en las negociaciones están por comenzar
será a las 4 30 cuando den inicio y pues
ya están definidos los representantes
tanto de la oposición como por parte del
gobierno
las maduras